[Music]
where are we
Detroit I can't hear you Maggie Detroit
again I grew up around music it's my
whole world got one more song for y'all
tonight if you told ball drilled me that
one day I'd be working for Grace Davis
she's an icon this woman doesn't even
know your last name she does sometimes
[Music]
you're not
[Music]
and the girls still give me goosebumps
well grace
have you thought anymore about the Vegas
residency actually I think it's time I
record a new album I mean that's one
plan what am I supposed to say to her
I'm just a personal assistant but I'd
love to produce your music do not sell
yourself short you study composing
Maggie has there been a new great status
record in a decade and the fans want one
number mention let me do my job and you
do your husband Cheers get her coffee
Kleenex Kotex and whatever state we've
been paying you to do for the last six
months I've been here for three years
you could pay so you were an intern my
life it's really bleak out there for
middle-aged singers in the history of
music only five women over 40 have ever
had a number one in and only one of them
was black
[Music]
I know everyone is happy with me doing
the same show every night grace you are
the song you should not be buried under
all this flashy garbage I didn't want to
tell you or Jack but I did a cut of your
song hey here y'all y'all knows the damn
microphone in there right
[Music]
all we got to do is play safe to stack
some money I will decide what I do next
[Applause]
if the food coming sir we've been over
this we are not a drive-through well a
chippy
it could be oh my god is that great
Steve
[Music]
you